this right over here is a screenshot
from a Khan Academy exercise and it says
Mason stands on the fifth step of a
vertical ladder the ladder has 15 steps
and the height difference between
consecutive steps is 0.5 meters he is
thinking about moving up down or staying
put so let me draw this this this ladder
that Mase isn't that Mason is on so it's
a vertical ladder so that's one side of
the ladder this is the other side of the
ladder and it has 15 steps let me see if
I can draw that so this is the first 1 2
3 4 which I'm going to run out of space
I need to make them closer together
so it's going to be 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 and 15
15 15 steps let me make sure it's even
so the top of the bottom and the
difference the the distance between each
of these I guess you could say steps or
the rungs of the ladder are half a meter
so this distance right over here is 0.5
meters and it says that he's on the
fifth step of this vertical ladder so
he's on the fifth step so 1 2 3 4 5 so
this is where he is right now he's on
this fifth step and he's thinking about
moving up or down or staying put
let H of n denote the height above the
ground H of Mason's feet F measured in
meters after moving n steps if Mason
went down the ladder and is negative all
right H of n so when so when he is the
height above the ground after moving n
steps so let's just as a make sure we
understand this if I were to say H of 0
what is that going to be well H of 0
means that he's moved 0 steps he's moved
0 steps he's still going to be on this
fifth step of the ladder and so how high
is he going to be so if he's on the 5th
step of a vertical ladder so he is going
to be so I'm assuming that there's 0.5
from the ground so this is the ground
right over here so he is 1 2 3 4 5 steps
each of them is half a meter so 5 times
0.5 is going to give us 2.5 meters so H
of 0 is 2 point 5 meters if I said H of
1 that means he goes up H of 1 means he
goes up one step so here n would be
equal to 1 so if it goes up 1 step H of
1 he's going to be 1/2 a meter higher so
is going to be equal to 3 meters so we
could keep doing that for a bunch of
different inputs so let me write that
that's going to be equal to 3 meters but
anyway that's not what they're asking us
about they're saying which type which
number type is more appropriate for the
domain of the function so the domain
that just as reviewed that's that's the
set of numbers that we can input into
the function and get a valid output and
it's clear here so we have to pick
between integers or real numbers well n
which is our input that's the number of
steps you goes up or down so it could be
positive or negative but we're not we're
not going to talk about half step C then
he'll put his foot in the air right over
here he has to take integer valued steps
up or down or I guess he's taking
integer value steps if it's positive
it's up if it's negative it's down if
it's zero that means he's staying put if
n is zero that means he's staying put
it's not real numbers he can't take he
can't take he can't move pi steps from
where he is he can't move square root of
2 steps from his he can even move point
0.25 steps then hit put his foot in the
air so this is definitely going to be
about the integers not the real numbers
this function right over here the valid
inputs if I want to be able to input an
integer in fact it's not even all
integers because he can't go down an
arbitrary amount in fact Li he can't go
up an arbitrary amount either but it's
going to be the domain is going to be a
sub set of integers and then they say
define the interval of the domain and we
have these little toggles here to to to
think about to define the interval of
the domain and let's see
the lowest value for n he can go as far
as 1 2 3 4 5 steps down and in that case
n would be equal to negative 5 and then
the highest value for n is if he takes 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 steps up and so that
would be n is equal to 10 so the
interval of the domain and actually I'm
just using I just copy and pasted this
onto my scratch pad he can n can be as
low as negative 5 and as high as 10 and
it can include them as well so I'm going
to use brackets so my domain would
include negative 5 if it didn't include
negative 5 output of parentheses but I
could put brackets here and I could put
brackets there as well and I can
actually let me just for fun let me
actually input it into the actual
exercise so I'm saying integers and I'm
as low and can I can go down 5 steps and
I can go up 10 steps and 10 is also
included in my interval then I could
check my answer and I got it right